kourin shown house in prison in
northeastern berlin embodies the 44
years of political persecution in former
East Germany among the thousands of
prisoners to pass through its gates was
83 year old honored rifki who served
five and a half years there that was the
worst time this little cell here was
isolated with no one to speak to except
the interrogator i was completely closed
off from the outside world no other
prisoner to see no letter no newspaper
no book in 1953 the their 19 year old
was imprisoned for military and economic
espionage inmates were often subjected
to physical and psychological torture to
extract information then there were the
night interrogations which were
constantly carried out so you had no
sleep and sleeping during the day was
impossible - after three days my nerves
were through and I told the interrogator
everything the Stasi was the most
important instrument and enforcing the
communist dictatorship in former East
Germany five decades after his release
Arno has many unanswered questions not
least of all why his arrest warrant was
signed by someone as high up as a vice
Stasi Minister after the fall of the
wall I saw my arrest warrant for the
first time and I was astonished that it
was signed by Erich Mielke and that it
was marked as a secret classified
document why is this the case this
wasn't another arrest warrants and why
did I get a single cell in 1962 just a
year after the construction of the wall
dividing East and West Germany Arno was
unexpectedly released due to the need
for more prison spaces his deepest
regret is the lost decade of his youth
1992 was the first time I was here again
as it was open to the public I drove
here with my wife but then I took a turn
for the worse I had nightmares at night
that they were arresting me again I had
screaming Fitz and my wife often had to
wake me up Christian
Padma Kofi freakin mission more than
five decades since his release the
memories of Horan Shirin Heusen remain
vivid but consequent visits with family
and tours with schoolchildren have acted
as therapy but some things will never be
regained